Hey, Dragons!
It's me, Donkeybird!
So, Respawn asked me to define my perfect Apex match.
Well, I don't think they've ever watched me play.
Because my definition of fun?
Chaos.
Lots of chaos.
Don't get me wrong, I love to get my squads back.
But accidents happen.
So, for those of you who like me, I'm gonna give you a little bit of a hint.
If you wanna drop in and fuck things up, allow me to introduce to you my main girl, Mad Maggie!
And tell you why she's the best.
I ain't gonna disappoint.
First off, I mean, look at her!
She's the most badass looking legend!
Her Wrecking Ball, it's absolutely fucking sick!
I'm just getting started.
And now her balls are even bigger!
I mean, come on!
Who doesn't like big flaming balls?
Plus, with double riot drills, you can go max attack in the final ring.
So, now you're like, sick!
I'm sold!
Maggie for Prez 2024!
Or maybe you're not!
Either way, she doesn't give a fuck if you don't like her.
And guess what?
Neither do I.
Come on, baby!
Let's play!
And what's even better is, she's free to play.
So jump in and come for us, the Chaos Queens of Apex!
You'll probably get an easy dub.
But I'll tell you more about her in the next episode.
Thanks for watching!
And I'll see you in the next one!